so I've been getting bombarded with
people asking me about how real this is
does this make sense why would that dude
pass at a billion dollars and I'm
laughing because in the video I think
Jimmy says that it would be at least 10
billion for him to sell his channel and
all the companies the Beast Burger the
chocolate all this and when I saw that I
was like not enough so people freaking
out at a billion I think 10 billion is
not enough and I don't think people
realizing what him and Emma Chamberlain
and Logan KSI and a drillion other
influencers that the people that are
creating content and building actual
Community beginning to build an actual
scale and then are able to deploy the
commodity of t-shirts and juices and
chocolate and cereals and burgers these
are all [ __ ] Commodities that are
being built on the back of actual
audience and affinity and caring about
it I think one day we'll look at when
Jimmy exits and we will laugh at the
building that he was offered people are
laughing that he's turning it down
people can't see the differences between
thoughtful business strategy and a flash
in the pan creators entrepreneurs
building massive humongous audiences
that's the actual asset